[Musique]
une année 2023 plutôt longue compliquée
qui se finit très très bien avec le
festival des lumières sauvages mais
c'est vrai qu'une météo des événements
et donc on a essayé de faire face toute
l'année et puis donc le le le le parc
est resté complètement ouvert et a
Contin continu
[Musique]
d'innover les naissances he plus d'une
centaine de naissances dont les ours les
Orix les lions récemment qui ont
quasiment 6 mois les deux petites
lionnes et puis les les les lodges
éléphants qui ont ouvert avec beaucoup
d'arrivé aussi il y a eu vraiment de
deux éléphants qui sont arrivés dans ces
dernière année dans cette dernière année
qui ont complété le groupe
puisqueaujourd'hui Ben qui était tout
seul et ben aujourd'hui ils sont tr et
avec un nouvel enclos aussi pour les
[Musique]
éléphants on a eu plus de 500000
visiteurs déjà il reste encore quelques
jours pour finir cette année 2023 on va
être un tout petit peu en dessous de
2022 mais pas de beaucoup pas de loin
[Musique]
2024 on travaille sur la circulation
douce et ce sera le premier pas puisque
les camions brousse partent juste après
les vacances pour passer en énergie
propre et devenir électrique et à partir
du mois de juillet normalement les deux
camions qui circuleront sera
complètement en énergie électrique on a
aussi une nouvelle zone d'hébergement
qui va ouvrir sur les lots artiques à
base de digucraft ce sont des petites
maisons en bois qui vont venir
agrémenter encore plus cette immersion
au cœur du monde
[Musique]
animal